[Musique]
en plein coeur du quartier des
spectacles un jeu de dominos pas comme
les autres géants coloré et musical
les gens ont vraiment envie de jouer
physiquement ne sont pas dans la
délicate et sa date on n'est pas dans un
jeu observe on est beaucoup dans
pensez-vous je veux pousser les deux une
autre oeuvre l'effet domino est composé
de six stations différentes pour un
grand total de 120 dominos géants
quelques jours plus tôt l'installation
était encore en atelier lorsqu'on arrive
de près de la station si les gens
touchent les dominos on va les réveiller
comme ça donc la lumière va s'allumer et
chacun des dominos va voir une
personnalité sonore
que des censeurs dans chacun des dominos
qui nous donne de l'information sur à
quelle vitesse et domino bausch qu'elle
est l'angle des dominos donc moi je
prends ces données là puis ensuite en
fonction de l'angle en fonction de la
vitesse
j'vais générer des processus musicaux
une année complète de production a été
nécessaire pour marier toutes les
disciplines technologiques de l'effet
domino si on a travaillé avec avec des
concepteurs sonore des concepteurs en
lumière des concepteurs au niveau du
design c'est autant d'enjeux c'est en
termes de mobilier que d'électronique
technologies un autre enjeu très
important
il a fallu réfléchir aux aléas de la
météo on doit donc être capable
d'installer une oeuvre pendant presque
deux mois sur dans le verglas dans la
neige dans la pluie ici on a du spa
matériel de piscine aussi nous envoyer
des boudins installation dans le frigo
on arrosait on on refermait la porte ont
dégelé ont recommencé
quelques jours avant l'inauguration on a
déplacé l'oeuvre vers le quartier des
spectacles
à peine installé l'effet domino et qui
déjà la curiosité
sous ce très coloré sous ce plutonium à
ses coûts oui j'aime ça pour les
couleurs et la musique c'est interactif
ça fait un peu de beauté de journée
d'hiver lèvres québécoise pourrait bien
répandre ses effets éclatant ailleurs
une volonté d'exporter leur
on a quand même prévu le tout un peu
comme des lego donc chacun des modules
peut être money peut être agencée avec
d'autres mais avant de peut-être prendre
la route
l'effet domino se fera sentir dans le
quartier des spectacles jusqu'au 27
janvier ici julie jasmin boudreau radio
canada montréal